you really feel like this I'm just
trying to judge based on your appearance
but let you get a question and you know
you ought to be able to figure it out
but it's still complexin you for some
reason and you're like I want to solve
it everything is he's you know I
remember doing I'm doing research about
motivation for because in my degree I do
like educational psychology which is why
I'm talking about Stanford Prison
what-have-you so I study psychology
because I wanted to know about go look
it up I wanted to know about what
motivates people right to learn
something and one of the answers people
had was well okay if they know that
something's gonna be used in the real
world like out when they finish school
in that kind of theory like okay well
that's going to be valuable like that
will make people want to learn something
because they think I'm gonna need to
learn this later so I will now and
people use the reverse logic when
they're like why should I have to learn
this because I'm never gonna need to
know this later like in my real life
right so people seem to use that logic
the problem with it is you think about
it for your own you know what you've
been going through and learning and what
you've most enjoyed learning over the
last I think most of you enjoy learning
things that actually really still have
nothing to do with real life and work
and like things you have to do with the
real world you just enjoyed learning
them because I give you a challenge what
they interesting right and this is a
classic example like I know her and I'm
not gonna pretend that you're ever gonna
use parametric's in you know real life
when you leave here even if you're like
an engineer or something you might need
to have like a basic understanding but a
computer otherwise they do it for you
but it's an interesting
then if you have a business you inflict
some other guy to do the mask for you
anyway okay my my way to get into this
question is first to finish off this one
so this is before this was the
intersection of the tangents okay and I
want to just back up a little bit and
just imagine okay we worked at the
restriction cuz we looked at it
graphically but suppose we hadn't done
that and suppose we needed to use the
discriminant method okay no we haven't
done all that many examples I don't and
it's confusing so I'm gonna do another
one so hopefully it all starts up
settled affair so if I'm at this point
I've done DP cr4 restrictions okay and I
just might decide I would use the
discriminant
I'm gonna have to have some poor try to
get something there somewhere back which
is why discriminant when it comes out
we're done okay so the question is where
will the quadratic appear if you
remember I come back a few notes
the key is that keep forgetting we get
the exact possesses the keys that we
need an equation or a lady X Y X I'm not
why because I want a restriction on the
domain not a restriction on the range
even though in some ways that might be
useful as well
I want an X restriction okay so I'm
gonna relate X to one of the parameters
okay it doesn't matter which one it is
okay but I need to get an equation with
X and just one of them just okay so I'm
gonna take this slide as my starting
point okay because I've already got X
and the parameters together okay so well
how do you suggest I get rid of one of
the parameters what could I do what
could I use what I got Kim oh you know
I've got two parameter
I'm gonna use this guy again right
because this relates the two parameters
together so if I can change the subject
of this same change the subject term Q
right and I can sub it and get rid of
all the Q's right so cue the subject
yeah so let's move that to PQ leaving
just the P on the other side yeah now I
factor I should take that okay should
now okay so good so wasn't gonna do with
that
good I'm gonna bring it here okay yeah
it does look terrible and this is why
most of you I need a 2 as well most of
you rightly avoid the descriptive method
for finding out the funny other
restriction okay and that's why some
teachers flat out their teacher okay
you've experienced that already but it's
gonna be useful for us in two minutes
when I finish this question and have a
look at the normals question okay so
what do you propose I do at this point
good let's do it 2-1
okay okay
remember where I'm going to end up I'm
gonna end up at a quarter attic equation
in P right so let's get to what full P
squared tick there we go but the
quadratic - okay all right let's get it
all on one side keep all of these guys
over
is for peace with minus 2 P X plus X ok
that one what was this what was this
method called again the discriminant so
I should maybe use the discriminant why
why am I using this command I want real
solutions sorry real solutions for haver
right that requires the discriminant
being ok so be careful because not a
quadratic in X so you just got to make
sure you don't confuse your letters B
Square what's B squared look at it it'll
be will be is minus 2 X so it's 4x
squared B squared minus 4 a 1 C let's
see okay good to find 3 by 4 i guess x
squared minus 4 X greater than equal to
0 and that is a parabola that hurtful
you recognize 0 4 okay so hooray I
landed at the same restrictions that I
got before which is a relief okay but I
think that is more work number 1 is more
work and number 2 it's conceptually hard
okay you're like what do I have to do
here and what kind of got to get the
order right in okay it's hot but you
can't avoid it sometimes